what's going on guys today i'm going to
explain some abnormal titans that have
appeared outside of the main attack on
titan manga
for those of you that haven't seen my
other video about abnormals that one
focused on titans created by isayama
himself with notable examples being the
talking titan and of course the massive
rod rice titan
this time around what we're going to do
is examine the freaky abnormals created
by other authors in particular the ones
that showed up in the no regret spin-off
and the before the fall prequel series
both of those stories have a bunch of
unique titans that never appeared in the
main show and as we continue the video
i'll also be giving my detailed thoughts
on whether either of them is officially
canon
before we get into it be sure to hit
that sub button if you want to see more
attack on titan content like this and
i'd appreciate if you dropped a like as
well as it does help out the video
okay so starting off with no regrets
this was the origin story of wiley by
joining the survey corps and the amount
of abnormal titans was different when
you compare the manga version to the ova
in the manga there was only one abnormal
which was 20 meters tall and i'm gonna
call this one the twisting titan because
whenever someone latched onto it it
would keep shaking its body around to
throw them off balance that type of
intelligence combined with its height
made it way more dangerous than a
regular pure titan but on their first
expedition levi isabel and ferlin were
able to take it down by launching a
coordinated attack for some reason
though the ova completely changed this
scene so that instead of the titan being
a 20 meter abnormal it was reduced to a
10 meter normal titan that didn't have
any special qualities
that's why in this version levi easily
killed it by himself without any help
from his friends which to me was a much
less interesting way of doing the whole
interaction the anime also added this
random abnormal that kept running and
jumping with both his hands raised in
the air although this one was quickly
dispatched by flagon who was the squad
leader overseeing levi and the gang
sadly by the end of the ova his entire
squad was killed by yet another abnormal
and this one was special for a couple of
reasons
number one it had red eyes which from
what i can remember is the first time
this has happened that wasn't just for
dramatic effect and number two it was
one of the few titans that was built to
move on all fours running on all fours
means its movement can be massively
unpredictable compared to what the
scouts are trained to come up against
and on top of that it attacked them
during a rainstorm where they could
barely see anything as a result it
caught the whole squad by surprise and
killed literally everyone who was there
with levi only rejoining the group after
the massacre was over
by the time he arrived the abnormal was
chewing fallen in half having already
ripped off isabelle's head and remember
these were the only two people levi
cared about in his life the ova did a
better job of portraying the unhinged
anger he'd feel after losing people to
the titans for the first time because
the way he tore it apart was even more
brutal than what he did to zeke
with that said the question now becomes
is any of this stuff cannon to the main
timeline and the answer to that depends
on whether you're talking about the no
regrets manga or the ova
isayama confirmed in chapter 80 that
isabelle and furlon were real characters
that existed in this universe as their
vestiges appeared in shiganshina as
everyone was talking to levi the problem
is that this doesn't confirm which
version of their story is the canon one
as even this flashback in the manga
wasn't enough to know for sure
thankfully in season 3 we got that same
flashback in animated form and in the
background you could see the skeleton of
the abnormal that killed flag on squad
this titan with red eyes never appeared
in the manga version of no regrets so by
skeleton being in the official attack on
titan anime that proves it's the ova
that's part of the main timeline
now moving over to before the fall this
prequel was mainly set around 50 years
before the main series and in it there
was a 10 meter abnormal who was the
overarching villain of the story the way
i see it this titan was the most
intelligent most muscular and most
savage pure titan that ever existed and
it terrorized the scouts on separate
occasions spanning well over a decade it
became so infamous that the survey corps
gave it the nickname ogre which is
appropriate considering ogres are
usually just ugly giants to eat people
with a few exceptions
starting at the very beginning of this
prequel many of the scouts had gone for
an expedition outside the walls when
ogre suddenly appeared but the thing
that really stands out is that he ripped
someone's head off and threw it back
over will maria the act of throwing
human body parts over the walls is not
something a normal titan would ever
think about doing but like i said ogre
was just twisted in the head and often
did things to cause extra pain for no
reason the head then landed in
shiganchana and splattered on the ground
and this was all witnessed by the
soldier's pregnant wife the woman who
saw her husband's head get thrown over
was called elena and she was so
traumatized by the events that she went
insane and ended up joining a
titan-worshipping cult but i'll talk
more about this when we get to the final
abnormal in the video for now all you
need to know is that the baby she was
pregnant with would grow up to be kuklo
who was the main character of before the
fall and someone who fantasized about
killing ogre for most of the series
around 15 years after the head-throwing
incident the scouts went for another
expedition when they were attacked by
this abnormal again and the way he
sprinted towards them was honestly
terrifying it was during this battle
that we truly got to see how sadistic
ogre was as he was killing soldiers in
the most creative ways and sometimes
didn't even bother to eat them
afterwards on one occasion he kicked a
guy like a football and sent him flying
into the atmosphere and a couple other
times he flattened soldiers for fun by
stepping directly on top of them he also
killed people by mushing them together
and squeezing with his bare hands and
his intelligence meant that he would
often pick and choose who he wanted to
kill rather than simply following his
titan instinct this was demonstrated
when he ran past kuklo who he should
have sensed first and instead tried to
eat someone who was hanging off the side
of wilmaria as you'll notice this scene
happened at night which is a time when
99 of titans stopped functioning so the
fact that he was full of energy and able
to run and jump in the darkness is
another example of his abnormal
characteristics
the issue with this prequel is that it
wasn't just ogre who could move in the
dark but in fact it seemed like a lot if
not all titans in before the fall had
this ability there was never an
explanation as to why this was the case
but on at least two separate occasions
titans were seen moving in complete
darkness before the sun was out making
them abnormal by definition naturally
some of them were more interesting than
others like this titan who appeared in
chapter 12 that was literally picking up
other titans and throwing them at the
main characters
the idea of a titan launching another
titan is something that we saw reina do
in season 2 but for a pure titan to do
it shows a level of intelligence that
you don't see every day
other interesting abnormals include the
beaded titan whose standout feature is
his amazing facial hair and the stealthy
titan which quietly crawled on all fours
to catch the scouts by surprise this
particular abnormal was super impressive
because it managed to be so quiet that
it avoided being detected by kuklo who
by that point in the series was like a
titan radar who could always sense when
they were approaching
finally the last abnormal i wanted to
mention was mammon whose death was
arguably the most important of any pure
titan in history as you'll see in a
second without this titan the cervical
would have been permanently disbanded
many years ago and if that happened then
it's hard to imagine what people like
armin and everyone would have done with
their lives
starting at the beginning malmon broke
into gigantic 70 years before the main
series when the front gate was opened by
titan worshipping cult this cult is the
same one that elena joined after she
went crazy and after mammoth entered the
gate over 5000 people were confirmed to
have died
at this point in the timeline odm gear
as we know it wasn't a thing and more
importantly nobody knew how to kill a
titan so the garrison and the survey
call were pretty much useless when it
came to stopping his rampage
in the manga we got a good look at how
ma'mon casually walked through
shigachina eating whoever he wanted and
at one point he cornered a bunch of
civilians and was picking them off one
by one
despite the crazy amount of victims the
royal government forbid people from
talking about this incident after it was
over and erase all traces of it from the
record something which i think is
believable given that we've seen mps do
similar things in the present day
anyhow the first person maman ate during
his rampage was the pregnant elena but
somehow her baby managed to survive and
was born once the titan vomited them out
hence why cuckoo was often referred to
as the titan son
other people eaten include karina who
was the assistant to angel alternan aka
the guy who would invent the odm gear
that we know today
it was due to his rage about karina's
death that angel single-handedly lured
mamon outside of shiganjina in a failed
attempt to kill the titan and being an
abnormal it completely ignored a crowd
full of people while it was chasing
after him
months later angel accompanied the
survey corps for an expedition to
capture a titan alive but just as the
sun was rising mammal managed to find
them again with only 18 out of 60
soldiers surviving the encounter
as i said no one at this time knew how
to kill a titan or that titans even had
a weakness so the surviving members
could only retreat back to wilmaria as
mamman followed them close behind
it was at this moment that a soldier
called sauron put an explosive in his
own mouth and then he purposefully
allowed himself to get captured by the
abnormal as the titan squeezed him half
to death he slashed it in the eye which
caused manual to let him go as soren
quickly stabbed into the nape so that he
wouldn't fall to the ground he had no
clue that the nape was mammon's weak
spot but he bit down on the explosive
anyway killing both human and titan in
the process
this was the first time in history that
a person from parodies island had killed
a titan and thanks to sorom the scouts
realized that titans do actually have a
weakness
sadly though because mama's body
evaporated like all dead titans do there
was no evidence that the scouts defeated
him meaning the royal government
publicly reported that the mission had
failed
as a result of the failure to capture a
titan the conservative politicians gave
the order to seal the game in shigachina
permanently so that it could never be
opened again and also the cervical were
meant to be dissolved had this gone
ahead then the timeline would have been
seriously messed up as you can imagine
but thanks to the knowledge they gained
from defeating mammon the scouts went on
one last unauthorized expedition to kill
another titan the success of that
following expedition is the only reason
why the politicians decided not to close
the gates for good meaning without
sauron's sacrifice and the knowledge
gained from it the cervical would have
stopped being a thing around 70 years
ago
last word to say about marmon is that he
was 10 meters tall and his name is a
biblical reference to the demon of greed
which makes sense considering just how
many people he ate in gigantic
now regarding the topic of whether this
is canon personally i think the prequel
expanded on the law of attack on titan
very well and there is some evidence
connecting it to the main series for a
start the ice bar stone was first
introduced in before the fall and
isayama later made this a plot point in
attack on titan so you know that shows
on some level that he acknowledges the
series but in my head there are two
things that potentially stop it from
being fully canon
the first thing is the unnatural amount
of titans that were able to function
without sunlight despite isaiah
establishing that this shouldn't be
possible hanji's experiments in season 1
showed that pure titans will eventually
run out of energy without exposure to
the sun and the only exception to this
rule were the abnormals created by zeke
in his royal blood
those titans were able to use moonlight
to function but clearly in this prequel
he couldn't have made ogre and the rest
of them as you know this was decades
before he was even born
the question then becomes did someone
else of royal blood make these abnormals
and you know while i think it's unlikely
there is one theory i have that might
explain it
we know that when carl fritz erected the
wars on parodies he erased the people's
memories making them believe that the
wars were there to protect them from the
titans years later that statement would
become true as marley kept on sending
pure titans to the island but in the
very very beginning there wouldn't have
been any titans outside the walls at all
i say that because when the aliens first
moved to the island mali was having a
civil war at the time and i'm not sure
sending titans to parodies was a
priority so at least for a while the
island was completely safe in this time
of peace it's theoretically possible
that the founder himself made some pure
titans just to make his story more legit
to the garrison soldiers who'd be
standing on top of the walls
if those soldiers never saw titans then
they might start to doubt if the story
corporates to put in their mind was true
so by creating a few abnormals and
sending them to the outside then the
fact titans are real would never be
disputed by anyone
if they were created by the founder
himself then that's the most plausible
explanation you're gonna get as to why
they can move in complete darkness but
let me know in the comments down below i
know this is a crackpot theory but it's
the the best thing i could come up with
to explain why this is the case
the second thing that makes me wonder if
this is canon is the existence of george
piccarli who was the former commander of
the survey corps
george's very existence contradicts the
main series because in bystander which
is one of my favorite chapters keith
sharda stated that he was the first
cervical commander to be alive to see
their successor until him all previous
commanders had died before their
successor was named so the fact that
george was alive to see your son carlo
lead the scouts is a direct
contradiction i guess in theory you
could say that keith is an unreliable
narrator and maybe he doesn't know all
the facts but when it comes to this it's
really something he should know for that
reason the existence of george implies
that before the fall can never be 100
canon although like i said maybe keith
just didn't know what he was saying
anyway guys thank you for watching this
video and if you enjoyed it then be sure
to drop a like and hit that sub button
so you don't miss future content like
this
until the next one peace out